venu pour toi il est venu pour vous
franchement il va nous faire des trucs
de ouf c'est un magicien exceptionnel
qu'on voulait vous présenter c'est ce
qui m'a dit il faut que tu vois ce gars
très très net joue et maman ça va leur
faire très plaisir voilà de le voir il
est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
alors eux ils se disent hier il ya une
balle alors il ya pas de vannes alors
mon chéri que tu vas nous faire ce soir
alors en fait j explique je suis pas
venu ici pour faire des tours de cartes
avec des balles en mousse ou quoi que ce
soit vraiment vous montrer ce que c'est
la vraie magie dans une nouvelle sphère
on est bientôt en 2020 il est temps
d'innover de changer de faire des choses
nouvelles donc on va on va commencer tu
peut désigner une personne en fait je
veux parler pas complices n'ont pas vu
avant je ne connais pas on s'est
vraiment fait prendre quelqu'un
d'innocent
ouais ouais tu vois tu prends quelqu'un
d'innocent aller aurait bondi à prendre
je peux prendre des bouteilles ou pas
revient sur la vie dans les bois des
bouteilles vides des bouteilles pleines
madingou ok c'est quoi ça bon ça c'est
un les urines de moteur en fait je
désigne tu vas comprendre pour acter
accord d'accord mais bon j'ai serré
d'accord âgées étaient bien là bas soit
après c'est d'avoir besoin de toi à
dimanche quand on va prendre une
bouteille d'eau
en fait ici je vais essayer de donner
des ailes à tout public a suivi du volet
des chroniques je vais vous expliquer
comment fait on peut aussi ça va durer
un peu un peu de temps on va essayer
d'accélérer le processus j'ai offert une
démonstration et beaucoup de gens qui
viennent avec des choses préparées que
ces terres etc
non on va essayer de faire on va essayer
de transvaser de l'eau dans une autre
bouteille d'eau avec celle ci au milieu
donc vous connaissez tous ce slogan de
ce qui donne des ailes
oui bien sûr c'est quoi nombre est
exactement donc rester très sûr fanta et
boogat voilà je vais prendre j'ai
demandé aussi à la régie de me ramener
quelques fourchette quelques mois la
voilà la région va très bien cet été
près d'accord voilà je vais demander de
de bien observer ce qui va se passer
d'accord donc une bourde holloway la mer
exactement
regardes tu vas toi même prendre je
faisais que ça donne des ailes en tu vas
t'en même prendre la bouteille membres
du mois par ici pour te monde puisse
voir regarde
normalement si tu observes bien d'accord
faut pas un seul bruit mais regarde si
tu observes bien jadis avait donné des
ailes d'accord mais regarde il faut il
faut absolument se concentrer
c'est quelque chose que jamais était
encore vivante et les mets ont valsé ne
bouge pas rien ne bouge pas regardes tu
vas sentir normalement regard tout
doucement la matière et votre transverse
et la bouteille et 7 mètres plus au
dessus avant soit un peu plus un garde
et si on y croit normalement vous
commencez à voir la transformation
regardez bien c'est pourquoi la
bouteille regarde non pas toi tu sais
bien c'est bon je vais donner à thierry
s'arrêteront à l'envol bernard voilà
alors série dames pour jonathan
ouais bernard pour l'instant on a on a
juste créé le red bull on n'a pas mis du
gaz à l'intérieur d'accord donc il va
cirer là la bouteille tu vas compact et
la bouteille
d'accord mais tu vas sentir une pression
fut prise sur dans la bouteille d'accord
et au compte de 3 normand je vais
demander d'ouvrir la bouteille qui va
entendre le cheat du gaz qui s'est formé
un terreau de la bouteille d'accord je
l'offre que si je reçois pas d'un la
gueule mal à l'inquiéter regarde deux
trois ou l'eau ouais tu peux sentir
goûter savoir si c'est vraiment dur et
deux côtés moi je peux vous dire j'ai
fait quelque chose qui donne des ailes
lauryn hill et café by cc du la marque à
la presse ainsi sa durée car j'étais qui
apparaît bull ouais ah ouais je te jure
ça sent
[Applaudissements]
tu vas prendre une fourchette d'une
cuillère contumace différents normal
j'ai passé pour moi j'ai appris la
prochaine fois qu'on prend de suite on
fait des gardes tu fasses aux couleurs
chaudes comme moi d'ailleurs une fois
une seule fois la secousse au concours
ce coup ça fait rien non c'est pourquoi
ce parce qu'en fait elle est très
sympathique dans ton corps c'est
pourquoi parce qu'en fait elle fonde la
seule personne à pouvoir travailler le
métal un franc le long première en verre
de thé s'il vous plaît
regardez bien c'est la seule personne à
faire à pouvoir faire ce que tu vois ce
que tu vas faire ici regarde bien
tout le monde voit ici ouais ouais cyril
tu peux prendre là la fourchette avec
deux doigts
ouais bon regard qu'elle va bien tu peux
taper sur le sol voilà enfin là dessus
doucement mélange mélange à pelleter
mélange l'ange gardien tous mentent eu
peu relevé la fourchette
[Applaudissements]
ouais
cki de graines noires et un dernier truc
ou pas vous faire j'ai demandé à mokhtar
alors il a bien besoin
on m'a demandé de faire ce spécialement
merci mokhtar en fait je sais le faire
devant toi ouais bon criardes mon corps
je peux venir ici pourquoi tu regardes
mokhtar tu vas me soulever d'accord
d'accord soulève mois sans fléchir les
jambes tu me soulève asie soulève moi
c'est bon ça s'en ressent
tu peux me retrouver maintenant mais
regarde en fait j'ai enlevé toute sa
force d'accord maintenant regardons à
temps regarde bien passé sous la tente
les chaises en bouffon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cela dit